[Música]
había una vez dos ranas
la primera y la segunda rana
la primera gala hacía todo de primera
y la segunda todo de segunda
si la primera gana brincar a un charco
la segunda rana también
si la primera rana atrapaba una mosca la
segunda rana
si la primera no se ponía a tomar el sol
la segunda semana
si lo primero que nos invitaba a la
suegra del domingo la segunda rana no
era bueno pero no eres tú
un día la primera rana cayó en una
inmensa olla de leche y la segunda rana
también
pero la primera rana se detuvo
calculó el alto de la olla el diámetro
de la olla la cantidad de leche dentro
de la olla la cantidad de grasa que
tenía les la leche dentro de la olla
cálculo planeo verifico visión no
imagino
llego a la conclusión de que se iba a
ahogar
y efectivamente
sí aunque cuando la segunda rana vio
aquello empezó a patalear ya patalear ya
patalear como una loca
tanto pataleo que convirtió la leche
mantequilla
y cuando tuvo una base sólida
simplemente
eso me hace pensar que los que nos
movemos tenemos una ventaja sobre los
que se quedan así sentados así que un
aplauso para los que nos movemos
[Aplausos]
y claro así como la quijada de burro fue
tecnología los libros y los cuentos
también porque impulsa una cosa que se
llama imaginación
quien dice que un helicóptero no fue un
sueño loco de leonardo da vinci
quien podría negar que los viajes al
espacio no fueron una fantasía de julio
verne
quien podría poner la mano y decir que
nosotros no somos un sueño de alguien de
alguien que alguna vez
no estuvo allí dibujados como una idea
y por eso esta mañana les traigo un
cuento viejo
para tiempos nuevos
viéndolos así de reojo podría pensar que
tal vez somos todos del mismo barrio
tal vez si tal vez no ustedes dirán
porque cuando yo estaba chiquilla
espacio mental para que todos piensen en
parque jurásico
imagínense los dinosaurios
cuando yo estaba chiquilla un día como
esto pero como dentro de un mes
la maestra
entraba al aula
con un puñito de unas barritas de cal
que se llamaban tiza
tecnología
no habían palos para las pisadas
y se nos quedaba yendo así así
como si supiera algo que nosotros no
agarraba la barrita de tiza rosada y
ponía en la pizarra que era de palo de
madera o verde negra
mañana
celeste
fiesta
verde
blanca
la
roja
alegría
y todos nos quedamos así como way the
wind de yunta
y ustedes la alegría
eso lo único que quería decir es que
podíamos ir a clases con la ropita de ir
a misa
y cuando no llegaba estaban todas las
mesas pegadas a la pared como un
papelito periódico blanco
nada electro ni la sombra del día no así
pelao
con una servilleta que adentro traía man
y galletas siempre añejas
yo no es consistente este vuelo que si
usted se lo sacaba de y adiós
pero a la par a la par de las
servilletas había lo que yo digo como un
whatsapp del cielo
porque había una manzana
y las manzanas no se compraban ni en las
rotondas ni en el super ni en la feria
solo en navidad venían de la hicimos en
un concierto pino con aserrín que
después se tenía y servía para los
caminitos del portal
y yo le decía abuelita abuelita dónde
vienen las manzanas medios hoy en el
extranjero yo si hay a dónde queda están
ja
pues una grava la manzana como en el
señor de los anillos hay dos muy precios
my pesos
y es que las vacaciones comenzaban en
noviembre por una razón estratégica
porque había que ir a café costa
rica vivía del café y del banano y si no
se coge el café la pasamos muy mal
entonces las vacaciones comenzaban en
noviembre y terminar
hasta marzo
eran tan largas que repartíamos unos
papelitos que decían de sus vacaciones
y hay algunos con anillos de tapa dura
que decían al mundo el recuerdo
entonces no agarraban de la página más
planchadita y se lo llevaba la maestra
como en el ofertorio
niña me pone algo en el álbum
la maestra ponía un verso que siempre
del mismo todos los hacen el agua no se
puede marchitar dos amigas que se
quieren
alta
del mismo
ah
y así comenzará las vacaciones lo que
pasa es que los que podían ir a
café se levantaban temprano manga larga
canasto de sus colchones almuercito en
hoja las medias como superman encima de
los pantalones porque iban a café
y eso era una cosa muy buena se hacía
buena plata el aguinaldo la navidad los
útiles todo salía el buen café pero
nosotros no nosotros éramos ratas de
ciudad
y entonces pasábamos las vacaciones en
la increíble casa de mi abuelita
que quedaba dos casas de la me
una entrada por el patio o por la calle
la casa de la abuelita tenía un zaguán
un pasillo así largo largo eran más
largos y una variedad en moto
las paredes eran altas y oscuras y univ
entrando así entrando entrando y veía
que en las paredes estaban las fotos de
mis tíos y de mis abuelos que como no se
usaban los el fish todos quedaban en las
fotos así
y hay que hablar o si usted se quedaba
viendo los ojos y caminaba para allá el
viernes él es quien decide
y si al otro lado el roquillos de la que
ayer
encima de cada cuadro habían cruces de
palma bendita de palo de metal y uno le
decía abuelita abuelita que eso me esas
cruces y ella decía
son todas las personas que se han muerto
en esta cara
eso ayudaba a la unión familiar
porque me apunta nos quedamos solos
[Aplausos]
andamos peros pegao viendo que no
pareciera un pariente que no pegara los
pies del piso
y es que abuelito tenía la maña decirme
machista vaya al último cuarto donde
murió su tío fringe o
nuevamente innovación ahí nacieron las
redes sociales porque uno le decía a los
primos me acompaña
y los infelices contestaban
por eso los chiquillos jugábamos en una
cosa que tenían las casas que era
extraordinaria patio
árbol de guayaba árbol de jocote vástago
en el centro aquí una cama de seda zonas
y chayote y por allá donde un yo viera
fuego las gallinas
entonces todos jugamos en el patio las
chiquillas
pero habíamos sido mandona les decíamos
a los varones ustedes vengan de aquí
para allá
nosotros jugamos aquí debajo de la
chayotera juegos proféticos
de casitas
todo lo que va a hacer todavía
yo lo hago es que estoy yo lado los
cantos
pero los hombres los hombres jugaban muy
lindo conseguían unas tablas para los
unos roles todo regalado tecnología
y si hace algunas patinetas donde de
viaje en que habían 3
con un cartón grande y lo llenaban de
candela derretida tecnología
y nos invitaban a jugar chiquillas
quieren irse a tirar de la cuesta en el
día
y quien me va a querer
[Música]
y no iba a querer ir con aquellos bento
aleros de enero las ramas pasando así el
magma cuco decía me suelto me suelto y
nosotros decíamos suertes de suertes
veíamos las estrellas como frank lynch
ah
ahí quedó el coro la jeta la nalga la
rodilla es todo
y alzamos donde abuelita como the
walking dead
mi abuelita me he hecho yo
si usted a los 10 de la mañana tenía
hambre se iba al palo de guayaba ganaba
una criolla verde por fuera rosa y está
por dentro le metía un mangazo y salía
no peor que un gusano medio gusano
porque usted se había tragado la otra
mitad
no sé quién era como un bate andaba
comiéndose todo lo que veía o me van a
decir que nunca comieron frijoles
si de verdad le quedan así de ellos
sí porque los que estaban dos estaban
miedos del perro
si usted todo solo cambia las casas no
tenían alambre navaja ni cosas de
electrificar sino una matica que así
pueda van con machete con una flor roja
la amapola
uno ha llegado así si no saben cómo eran
en youtube hay un tutorial pero de todas
maneras le voy a decir ustedes habrán
quitado la flor así poco y se tomaban un
juguito dulce
y enseñaron por qué sirve la tecnología
y el conocimiento si usted no lo hereda
vea lo que yo sé hacer le decía uno de
los tributos
ahí fue donde todos aprendimos a fumar
mecha
pero no hacéis
abuelita se paraba y nos llamaba por los
dos nombres y libre los dios libro los
dioses que ustedes los llamen por los
nombres como en el seguro cordón para
esta lista
llevamos todos así pegados a la pared
pegados a la pared y abuelita empezaba a
rezar el rosario pero ahora que hablaban
de que las ideas hay que compartirlas
ahora que hablaban de que la idea vale o
no vale según usted pueda compartir la
vida la había prescripciones porque
usted no se podía reír ni podía che
estar en los rezos y abuelita que era
como google todo lo sabía
empezaron a estar muy raro y decía santa
maría madre de dios en la carrera por
nosotros pecadores
entonces nos decía así en la nube como
decía un germán que hijo
protección de datos que dijo
en la nube
santa maría madre en la carrera por
nosotros pecadores uno sabe que la vida
en marcha y de ojos azules pero para
decirles la gasta mucha confianza
santa maría madre de dios de las gatas
que se está poniendo ante ellos
y nos daba risa
y eso no podía pasar porque si a uno le
daba risa venía el pellizco la jalada de
pelo los ojos torcidos y los cascos
pero porque lo traigo esto aquí porque
porque así abuelita nos marcaba una raya
en el piso invisible
virtual que nosotros sabíamos que no se
podía atravesar
si en esta mesa había una moneda de 2
pesos que no era de nadie tampoco era de
uno
había que decir a dónde íbamos con quien
a qué hora volvíamos reglas elementales
de sociabilización buenos días con
permiso
me presta le doy y si bien es cierto que
el mundo es de los que toman lo que está
por ahí también es verdad que en esa
costa rica un día abuelita agarra una
docena de huevos y me decía vaya a
llevarle a doña dices que tiene tres
chiquitos con hambre y un marido sin
trabajo y no se distraiga y cuando yo
tocaba la puerta salía la señora con el
delantal todo mojado y medio hoy yo
partido hortensia no cebolla y me traigo
un platico de arroz con papas que era su
manera de decirme gracias
y así pasaban los cuartos de frijoles y
pasaban los bananos y los chayotes y así
era una costa rica más sencilla pero más
solidaria
y presentación que tiene que ver con mi
abuela
también tiene que ver con que yo podría
ser la mamá de ustedes y también podría
hacer que sus hijos fueran mi nieto
fernando y yo tenemos una hija de 35
años por esta que no es millennial
linda la condena inteligente como no hay
dos y siempre pasa triste
yo todavía no tengo nietos pero ella
tiene gallo y dicen que gallina que
tiene gallo amanece con huevos
y cómo hay que andar adelantados ya yo
le hice una canción a mi nieto a esos
hijos que tal vez ustedes tengan y que
yo desde mi trinchera de periodista o de
narradora oral o de cuentacuentos puedo
entretener y decirles que el mundo no es
como es ahora el mundo podría ser como
en esta canción que hice que se llama
recuerdos del futuro
y había muchas cosas de cartón y de
papel
y la gente sonreír sin saber bien
y había muchas huellas marcadas en los
caminos
y había mil destinos por nacer en
caballos
entonces ser el mundo una enorme carroza
ha quedado suelto y vuelto a grabar
y aunque nada del todo marchaba del todo
había la esperanza y había un poco de fe
y había el pan fresco ambiente
cada día
se hacían poemas muy bonitas melodías
a todas las parejas
[Música]
muchas noches por debajo de los días
entonces el mundo
y bueno
sobre un barco de papel
más
aunque nada del todo marchaba del todo
había la esperanza y había un poco de fe
todas las personas caminamos de la mano
en pos de un mundo nuevo en busca de sus
hermanos
y todos le teníamos al blog y a la popa
y todos presenciamos el odio y las
osadas
nada era como ahora
qué escuchas a tu abuela
con esta voz de alambre
por la computadora
[Aplausos]